kein wunder dass die runde mit marie 25
und weiter fragen jetzt eigentlich
geschafft um wieder nach hause kommen
aus einem alten dran schwierig da die
musik gehört ich denke mal die waschen
durfte hey boss
ich war niemals im sumpf nur mein geld
verloren dadurch dass ich wusste dass
ich gar nicht im sumpf drin bin sondern
nur mein geld verloren habe habe ich es
geschafft habe ich gesagt ich bin ja
trotzdem was wert jeder mensch ist was
wert auch wenn er kein geld hat auch
wenn er meint wegen probleme hat ein
[ __ ] hat ein holzbrett pickel an der
backe ist jeder etwas wert und man muss
auch die stunden der zeit nutzen man
darf nicht auf dem sofa sitzen bleiben
mit einer flasche bier in der hand und
auf sein großes glück warten sondern man
muss es anfassen und sagen gut ich tue
mein bestes selbst wenn ich niemals aus
dem sogenannten sumpf denen ziemlich
einig gebt niemals rauskommt so ist es
trotzdem gelebtes leben so geht das und
so sind es